and a good afternoon to you thank you so
much for joining us at four on this
friday i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas we hope you
had your umbrella handy today
once again several parts of the valley
saw rain snow and even hail
over the past few days we've seen
everything from this very chilly wet
weather to
sunny skies so what can we expect in the
days ahead
let's begin now with our team coverage
we have madison kimbrough who is live at
the base of kyle canyon road plenty of
snow there
and earlier reports of snow in parts of
henderson and summerlin but first
let's go to chief meteorologist ted
florento with how much longer we can
expect this wacky weather to stick
around and
exactly how much rain we got today dad
hey kirsten yeah it's just been
incredible a couple days here with
rain snow graupel hail just the whole
gambit of everything outside right now
we still have plenty of clouds out there
even some showers still coming down at
this hour now
as we go to our radar and we back this
up six hours or so you could see that
the rain
changed over the snow we talked about
that anthem seven hills far west side of
the valley out near red rock the 215
beltway saw those big snowflakes
now the latest image on our radar does
show we did have a few isolated storms
that brought us grapple and small
hail right now right there shows us some
light shower activity coming down
at this hour that doesn't mean we're
done just yet either because we still
have
more in the forecast as we get through
tonight in fact
the national weather service extended
the winter storm
winter weather advisory for the
mountains and lincoln county until
4 a.m tomorrow morning this winter storm
warning applies to up there at cedar
city up there in utah so that's been
also upgraded meanwhile we put this out
on social media for the day today too
49 degrees the high means we had the
coldest
high on record for this date the
previous record
was 51 degrees set back in 1990 so all
we could get was 49 degrees
for the high today way below average for
this time of year we've also had the
second latest date for snow
the latest date we've had snow at
mccarran reported was march 14th so we
came in second place for that
and of course that cold record high
applies for the day today
we'll have more on what to expect for
tonight because showers and
isolated thunderstorms even some rain
snow mix are still in the cards for this
evening
in the meantime though let's head over
to madison kimbrough and photojournalist
tim zitlow have been
all over the valley today they started
in anthem seven hills now near mount
charleston
it's melted there but we still have
plenty of snow going their way up there
right madison
yes ted it seems like every part of the
valley got some type of weather today
take a look behind me where you can see
the mountain tops filled with snow
currently no snow on the ground here at
the base of kyle canyon
however plenty of snow not far from here
as you drive up
as i mentioned this area wasn't the only
place to experience some chilly weather
take a look at video set in by eight
news now viewers this video was taken
in the seven hills area that's between
eight and nine
this morning what started out as a quick
rain
quickly turned into snow you could see
snow
sticking to rooftops over by red rock
country club
that's in the west valley summerlin area
many people shocked to experience this
weather in march
a common occurrence in other parts of
the country but for vegas
a surprise to visitors like dylan foo
we actually heard that it was snowing
and we were going to go snowboarding but
we didn't make it up this morning so
we just took a drive up found a spot and
went off to the side of the road to
sled and stuff
several other people i spoke with said
that days like these of course
are just something that they really love
they love the cold weather
and a reminder if you are heading up to
mount charleston you must bring your
proper gear we're talking about snow
tires
chains a four-wheel drive that is vital
if you want to come up here and enjoy
the cooler temperatures
and the possible snow that still left up
on the mountain
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now